only a strong and united europe then
together with our friends and
allies in north america also the
necessary dialogue with the ost now so that
the sheep of the balance would find
necessary for the preservation of peace
in the world
the german east berlin the gdr
wall and barbed wire peacefully
overcome
after almost three decades of separation,
the people of germany celebrated a
fresh video seeing the
togetherness of unity
we need a strong europe a high
with self-confidence if we don't
want to become a pawn in world politics
thank you again we all need
europe if shareholders have a static
idea of ​​the  nineteenth century
there is no step across the threshold
to the twenty-first century
volpi reform policy this new
democracy in central eastern europe is also
in the well-understood self-interest of the
european union
[music]
wherever borders are freely
crossed, where ideas and opinions
are freely exchanged and where people
can come together
Mistrust and enmity don't stand a chance in the long run
and the best guarantee for
a lasting and secure peace
in Europe is and remains the freedom
of the people
[music]
[applause] [
music] [
applause] [
music]
[applause]
[music]